welcome to this video playing the French
defense yeah that's the name of the guy
and here he offers it I don't comply
let's see what he's doing here in the in
the Dutch playing it in nimes Oh Jim's
old Indian fashion okay i don't i don't
want the double porn so play it like
that now try to establish valve hmm
that's very uncommon as the bishop is
normally going to be seven okay maybe I
can quickly try to expose the wider the
light squares okay in fact I can all
right he's playing this very quickly and
this is this is just very bad for black
the light squares now are are a total
catastrophe and I will try to exploit
this with with the later f form I wonder
who I can I can start with this and then
aged 3 + f4
yeah i can start with h three okay he
does not want night at 5i I guess but
that's not the end of it also he also
has some other are the weaknesses let's
see what is the best way to do this
okay let's let's do it in a simple
fashion attacking a form and I will know
he just gives me the pawn right so I'm
but he couldn't really prevent that yeah
okay do not don't ask twice just take it
and he still has this pretty dreadful
bishop 127 yeah that's that's square
that the night definitely wants to be on
um what is the plan can go fall for a
four or just try to improve here maybe I
can still try to improve here but the
night on b-52 keeps his heaven under
pressure possible ideas Queen c3 and the
later f4 so g3 later form not sure how
much this this is really really netting
me let's let's improve this a bit you
could argue that a 3 B 4 is more more
according to the position bday the a
porn is already a passer so I don't mind
you just fortify this a bit and then go
then go from them how exactly yes still
I'd like to get an F for if possible and
just
queen bee three king h 2 g-3 and then f
form okay this is what he was add okay
so i don't mind to have the d5 square in
addition yeah all that okay need to take
and yeah probably probably just take
that hmm yeah that's nice your voice
very nicely blocking this it's probably
trying to get some count to play with
look to be aid okay maybe let's let's
regroup to see form and detect the a
poem Jeff again managed to be much down
on the clock
yeah it looks very solid for white don't
don't really see much counter play
coming now if I this week I just try to
to keep keep the weaknesses on the
bottom take here
i can play hope you want yeah i'm
just-just very slow mr. must play fast
i'm taking only five it's not a good
idea you to do to this this possible pin
gee I wonder if I have some some hi
morning a way to set up my pieces here
it's not totally easy him right to g4
maybe now maybe I can probably get get
out of this bloody diagonal well my back
row anchor my background is an issue
no still s his own his own King position
s is very weakened I'm going to check
the exchange to break through him let's
see it should be very check very
difficult to to to defend Knight f6 as a
huge threat oh it's not check reacting
to it at all I maybe had no defense
check check just the simplest possible
method i will just no need to push my
pawns black resigns ok this is this
should win but it's not so not so so
easy with the with the time the time
deficit he basically got into trouble
right in the opening I mean this is
frankly just not playable you cannot
play that him in this in this situation
you are deadly weak on the light squares
I have a bad bishop only seven this is
really a bit too much to to stand and
it's a very very difficult form for
black to to to to play this position I
have many possibilities I can also play
be three or something like that try to
prepare before in the long run but I
didn't
I didn't mind those those moves much yet
here he's just just be giving away the
pawn basically took me how to recognize
that but okay now I'm just the pawn up +
this always this night against the
stupid bishop on each form so it's a
very very nice position may be here
somewhere I can play more precise rooked
you one yeah those little things this is
this is even stronger if he goes g5 now
I can just play it like this and
something like this with one pair of
loops exchanged this this gets quite
easy to play and I kept like it f three
groups f3r up the 155 I'm just using all
the light squares and then wait okay
well what what I did is also very good
but it's not that convincing in
comparison 193 would have been good okay
I was just too busy trying to figure out
a position where he has no counter play
but really I just I keep my my winning
position and I takes you five okay but
this is certainly good yeah check it
also has a win yeah there were bit
better with some better squares but this
is this is so just just fantastic for
white I will pick up the hope this all
pawns and and still have a big attack
and was just this lost lost right away
it's um it's really not much that you
could do about this the whole opening is
the problem 'if is a strange move I mean
you just play Bishop e7 here and
continue like just like this and nothing
nothing particularly bad is going to
happen if i go here then you maybe can
consider this with the night losing a
ton of moves but I probably played this
something like that would be a normal
course of development okay thanks for
watching